[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
wow
[Laughter]
welcome back to dirty arty
we've done outer worlds but before there
was outer worlds there was red dead
redemption and now we're doing red dead
redemption 2 again
and this time it's pc and the reason is
because
uh you can now mod the game and uh
over on the internets we saw that you
can make models scale
very large or very small including
arthur morgan
nice that's a nice shot uh my name is
rob this is jake we're back at it right
jake
we're back at it although not nice
enough of a shot who's getting away and
he's gonna
tell the cops on me i don't know is this
like an open gl what
what exactly are you kind of mod are we
dealing with here
so the mod is from
i forget the name but you found a way to
open up this game
and mess with the scales and so we're
just gonna do that that's really it
we're going back to our roots here with
dirty arty
[Music]
what should we do everyone ignore player
oh
you're you're revolvers it's not
it's me
why it's like it doesn't scale
like certain elements we're looking at
here aren't scaling well like your
your reins and your revolvers
this is too good
all right time to ride into town
you're so small it's so adorable
oh
you're just you're just a gun for hire
all this episode is gonna be is us
laughing at this stupid [ __ ]
please go to town okay i forgot how the
controls work a little bit but
as if this game wasn't slow enough it's
going to take you
years to get to the bar
yeah i guess i should have got a little
closer
oh no oh the biggest enemy yet
oh you're running out of stamina he's
just looking at you
what you looking at shut your mouth
i can't seem to get inside
this is so stupid
this is good
[Laughter]
it's like just stranding
your bt yeah yeah well
go go to normal and then go go be small
on the bar
it will take you forever to get to the
bar
oh whoa oh your beer
what happened to the beard
that's incredible oh man
that is some like freaky ass horror
stuff right there
let's see if i can crawl into that
okay damn straight up too big
yeah quit looking at me that guy's
looking up they're all looking
up that's so good oh i think his
gameplay starts here oh yeah you do
start to fight indoors
yeah wait a second
where are you
[Laughter]
i can't even punch it won't let me punch
oh there you go i can grapple though
[Laughter]
oh yeah he's done i think i just killed
[Laughter]
him
wait oh this is sick
oh my god red dead redemption 2 baby
oh my god
we do yeah we can do some diving dude
can you poo probably not i'd be sick
this game sucks
dude not gonna lie like this makes you
really appreciate the
model and animation of this bird when
you sing it
i know right up this close like it's
super
and the draw distances in this game are
insane
that's that's that's how dirty arty now
uh arrives at his destinations
he's a shape-shifter and he air drops it
oh please start gotta go turns into an
eagle flies away
all right follow the road
oh man you're real high up oh yeah oh
[ __ ]
but i got god mode on so it should be
okay
look how dirty he is too holy [ __ ]
there's something to behold proud
all right i'm not done yet i want a beer
too
i can only order oatmeal i know what to
do
excuse me
[Music]
it's natural now here we are again it is
a natural now oh whoa
what how does how the hell did that
happen i don't know
easy wait a second that was weird
he just buries his face in it
again
[Laughter]
when i make myself small i get more
beans
yeah it's got denim oh it's standard
there we go
now this little scary for a second all
right so wow that's pretty impressive
how quick that is though
yeah yeah you're right
[Laughter]
don't worry
this little man following people around
yelling at him
this is like the epitome of napoleon
complex
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
just this little guy running around
throwing tomahawks at people
no wanted level is a real beauty yes it
is
dirty already can unleash his full
potential
this town is [ __ ]
don't run for me
[Laughter]
what
[Laughter]
have you seen the show before i can't
see describe it to me
i can't see wait i have an idea
so fantastical
ladies and gentlemen for 10.
[Laughter]
all right i'm gonna give you a bit more
of a crowd it's like if you're a parent
and one of your kids just wanders up on
stage
it's just like wants to be part of the
show
[Laughter]
oh
excuse
[Laughter]
sam it's me dead man it's me that man
if you see my baby
all right i'm tired of this yeah get out
of here
show's over oh god
[Music]
uh tomahawk
semi-automatic pistol why not
super explosive ammo okay
[Laughter]
call in gun ship
eagle four has been dissing what the
heck
all right i guess we'll figure out what
that is
it's gotta be one that escaped from the
no is that your gunship
oh that's my gun [ __ ] legal four yeah
i don't know if i'm just seeing things
but i feel like this the animation
is like sped up in order to compensate
for like
like am i crazy it looks like
running a little faster so it's even
more terrifying
am i wanted didn't think so idiot
not only are you small with explosive
rounds
you have a giant eagle following you
around
you go four where are
all right sounds good
oh it's gavin oh i got gavin right here
for you
get out of the street i swear it just
[Laughter]
freezes
[Laughter]
[Music]
you know where we can get inside now we
can get inside the prison
oh all right eagle four
oh yeah sure just fly there stay close
to me you go for
mama bird and baby bird
[Music]
this is so dumb
look back can you see it it's above yeah
i see it
that's a big ass bird all right same
deal
and get nice and high oh airdrop oh yeah
hell yeah eagle four um preparing to do
an air driver
wait for the green light prepare to jump
we're doing it in three two one
he's quiet because he's used to it now
whoa
stuck the landing okay not that exciting
well maybe we'll use those in another
episode
oh my god repair
oh my god it's chaos just keep doing it
in the kitchen oh there's
that is cruel all right well that's
gonna do it for this episode
this this holiday special if you will
i don't know it's not necessarily
exactly the holiday
season but you know maybe it is what am
i saying it's a holiday special thank
you all for watching
we'll see you next time